when discussing the
prenup it's a need for you guys to have
a marriage contract or a prenup in the
laws of america that's a necessity
especially when you're coming into a
marriage and you have no
she didn't have to say it like that
who coming into a marriage without no
assets
you don't know me you don't throw my
life back home tensions rise between
shaida and bilal's ex-wife shahida
during part one of the tell-all an
opinion is like a news everybody has one
and on top of all that shade throwing
blousex reveals a reason why she
divorced him
and y'all her answer
is very similar to chada's complaints
i felt
like
i was receiving more of an email
or a father figure when
i was wanting to hear from
my husband
why did you catch shada's reaction
yes it was
somewhat of a lecture
patrick and thyese are all of us right
now well they say you keep repeating the
same lesson until you get it right
we'll get into how bilal takes it all
plus y'all ain't gonna work out and i
would say the same about you guys but no
it ain't gonna work out for y'all jabrie
was the star of the tell-all and if you
know anything about previous 90-day
fiance tell-alls you know that is never
a compliment you don't think aryan
benny's relationship is gonna work out
y'all fake y'all ain't gonna work out
damn
some might see it as him just expressing
himself but
in my opinion
it was unnecessarily mean but you know
what he met his match with patrick's
brother john
you happy you don't have a happy family
you won't
okay sparkles and your sparkles are
blinding me though bro man you know i'm
trying to i don't know if i can focus
something shining off your head boy you
can see that yeah not the double take of
john's head though
let's get into it
okay spackles
hey money day fans fam it's melisia
before we get into part one of the
season nine tell all which was
interesting to say the least
i chatted with emily and luckily kobe
got off work early
yes he's working so he was able to join
the chat and we talked about it all
what's your response to viewers who feel
as if you take advantage of your dad's
kindness
um well now you only see one side kay
wants to know why did you think it was
more important to spend money on a ring
and a wedding ceremony instead of saving
so you and kobe can get your own place
as a family
i
at first wanted to get married in our
home and just have like 10 people like i
wanted to keep it fairly small to hear
the rest of our conversation where we
talk about emily working their new baby
scarlet plus more make sure you
subscribe to entertainment tonight's
youtube channel so you don't miss the
interview by the way let me just say
this now i had a minor mic issue
my first time filming at home in a while
and i am no technician
but it's not that bad you'll get the
answers to your burning questions
just wanted to let you know
partially because of the perfectionist
in me i always want to make sure i give
you the best experience all right okay
on to the tell-all
two
folks
are pregnant
in baby news dais and patrick are
expecting as well as kyra and guillermo
congrats y'all
and oh yeah they had commentators for
the tell-all og 90-day cast members tim
and kenny i just need like a whole
segment with just jabri and ari
it was like the tell-all and pillow talk
mashed together which i honestly could
have done without but cute idea
when i came here it was a complete
shock all right let's get into what goes
down between bilal and shaida before his
ex comes out
blah went through it during the tell-all
he cannot catch a break with the show i
kind of bagged him basically to
be on it with me
i bet he will not be signing up for it
again
if i were him i wouldn't what was the
biggest shock for you so many
the prank first kobe tells balau his
thoughts on the prank he pulled on
shaida the prank was the worst prank
ever for me because
like you place her in a position where
everybody will feel like no this is a
gold digger
about the woman you intend to spend the
rest of your life with that's a good
point because i sure did think shadow
was a gold digger when she first got
here
next blouse takes another hit when ari
calls him out for having an answer to
everything
it's not a test it's just it's just
words of confirmation like we always
talk about the same thing we want to
build an empire together you know
are we yeah i just want to say well you
always have an answer for everything
and i think that's suspicious i feel
like you know you always want to
like oh no no but it's not like this
it's like this even with her like you're
always like you know and then you're
telling no you don't feel like this you
feel like this
i know a lot of y'all feel the same way
they transition into talking about shy
to slapping bilal upside the head and
mostly everyone agrees that he
overreacted by pulling over to the side
of the road on the highway and that is
when i realized when he pull us out of
the road i say you know what this man
kind of take a jog and say you're the
auditioner but you can't take you know
where's that one okay okay
i feel like
uh
i get where you're trying to go with
this miona but jabrie and bilal are two
totally different type of men not trying
to be shady or anything but because they
are two different type of men in my
opinion you can't compare their
reactions
again hindsight something i should have
did um apologize as well to overreacting
billau goes on to take responsibility
for doing the most in the car that day
which leads to this moment
the only moment
someone starts to show him love on the
set i want to say something i want to be
like you whenever i grow up
just the way you talk
and you always say sorry
that's like one of the most important
things because we get accept
but patrick came in and shut that down
real quick
he's a salesman i mean that's
he is an amazing salesman that is what
that is what we are all witnessing right
now
no one can really get their point across
and if they do
it's twisted and insane
manipulation and being a salesman i'm
i'm i'm watching it off
i'm not sure if i fully agree with
patrick on that
i know it may seem as if i make excuses
for below's actions from time to time
and that's definitely not the case
i just want to make sure we aren't
allowing the parts we may not favor
about him
to get in the way of us looking at the
full picture
it's cool not to like him but we also
have to be fair
yeah i'm a salesman but you're a
salesman you're something like we're all
like we all sell sure below might have
allowed his work as a real estate agent
selling homes to trickle into his
personal relationships he might also
need to work on accepting that it's okay
to be wrong
and he might have some manipulative ways
to sum it up he can have a ton of flaws
but i think it's only fair to consider
that he's also an educated man who for
the most part is well spoken
so in this case i'm only talking about
the tell-all here
i don't agree with how hard specifically
patrick was on him
because now he's in a place where if he
talks he's wrong and if he doesn't talk
he's wrong all because this picture has
been painted that he is solely this
manipulator as if he doesn't have any
positive qualities
it's almost like i'm dang if i do dang
if i don't okay patrick what do you say
they'll never stop like you can always
control the conversation
wait pause benny is off daydreaming he's
not even blinking
[Music]
he was not invested in this tell-all at
all
i noticed that from the beginning
okay
back to the serious talk it'll never
stop like you can always control the
conversation in a way because you know
what to say when to say you know how
when you say something how that person's
gonna react you know how to drop your
tone you know how to get people engaged
it's a habit now and how do you think
that manifests itself in their
relationship when she's saying something
he's like okay i understand what you're
saying but this is how i see it and then
he goes into his point yeah like i do
the pot calling the kettle black
and once again this is not me making
excuses for below's behavior he has some
work to do which we're clearly about to
see
but
i'm all about being fair i feel like you
like a sales person you have to say back
something because it always have to be
you have to always have to win that
conversation so is that what you just
saw overcoming objections
you know everything well like okay if if
if the comment is about your behavior
do you automatically say well but what
about your behavior as opposed to just
concentrating on fixing the behavior no
not really yes sean not really classic
socks the eggs yes okay
now we're getting passive aggressive now
okay you just said okay yeah like kind
of like shutting it down no i'm whatever
she says
if you would have said something other
than just okay
okay it still would have been an issue
tell me how you see it because i don't
even see how he can talk without there
being a problem now and the same man
that called him out for acting like a
salesman does it in his own relationship
goes to his point yeah like i do
yet no one is questioning him when he
talks
i don't get it bilal is still very close
with his ex-wife shahida she has agreed
to join us today and we're very excited
to have her everyone please welcome
shahidah all right the drama continues
we learned earlier in the season that
blouse ex shahida
is stern
i didn't come here to
play games today and she comes to take
care of business honey i came to tell
all today to state my peace there was a
breakdown in the communication with
chida and i and that caused a breakdown
with palau and i when the truth is
revealed he'll owe me an apology she
will too and
we can move forward in a positive space
from there i'm not sure what she expects
shaida to apologize for
in my eyes chada handled it pretty well
when shahida confronted her about
signing bilal's prenup i don't know how
well you know below or how long you've
known him but i know it isn't 10 years
or 15 years of putting in you know the
work that you see
that he has produced and so
you know the kids have been here
i have been here so i'm coming from that
point of view where he needs to protect
himself and for the children's sake yeah
well
i think that's a composition building
and i definitely need to have
and i think we haven't reached an
agreement when it comes to that
okay yeah i don't remember her stepping
out of line in any type of way if
anything
shahida crossed some lines
her approach was intense shahida blau
says that after 10 years of marriage
one of you fell out of love
is that how you would describe what
happened to your relationship sean gets
into the nitty-gritty real quick this
was a question i've always wanted to
know so i'm glad she asked
um we had had some issues for some time
and we tried to figure things out
for the sake of the kids shahida goes on
to reveal that she's the one who filed
for divorce from bilal
and shawn asked why and her answer pause
stop me in my tracks i wanted a best
friend i wanted a partner
and
i felt
like
i was receiving more of an eman
or a father figure when
i was wanting to hear from
my husband
so lecturing
you um
yes it was
somewhat of a lecture you know what
i would love to hear below's mom a
90-day mvp honoree
shout out to y'all
i would love to hear her reaction to two
women now
that we know of
having the same complaint about her son
that would be interesting and oh
shahida starts to talk about bilal being
a neat freak which was something that
also played a role in them separating
i told y'all below could not catch a
break this episode
they say relationships mirror you
they will put right in front of your
face the things you need to work on
is very particular about how he wants
the house
and so
when you have two small kids too
that
becomes a problem with how the house
could be in disarray so that
that makes you feel uneasy
side of
controlling
meet freak
lecturing
does it give you any reason to be
concerned that obviously that same
behavior is still there i'm seeing a
pattern i'll be fair
well in shaheeda's case you're still
young but as a woman who's 37 i still
want to work and help him
i want to work on us i'm not going to
give up on my relationships well shahida
did have one message for shaida during
the premiere episode i wish some luck
this whole conversation really puts
those words into perspective now
okay
what i have noticed
since shahida first came out here
if you have not looked at her shaida
okay
is i it's am i
seeing what is actually happening
yeah okay shada says she feels
disrespected that's why she's avoiding
looking at shahidah
i
still
didn't like
how she came at me
at my home in my kitchen
she said my home my kitchen
that subtle shade butt facts
it still hurts
when i first came here
i was hoping for us to have
a sisterhood
i was hoping for she and i to have a
friendly relationship
but when once you show me who you are
that's when i will withdraw back so if i
can just unpack it
she's saying that when i came to her
home
my tone which is still very intense
my delivery
um
was that of
in disrespect
but what i will say is
when discussing the
prenup it's a need for you guys to have
a marriage contract
or prenup in the laws of america that's
a necessity especially when you're
coming into a marriage and you have no
assets
damn who coming into a marriage without
no assets
you don't know me you don't want my life
back home that was that was shay
shahidah shadow must have meditated that
morning
because that was a very calm and
impressive reaction
plus i'm not sure where all this
animosity is coming from the prenup has
been signed so what's the problem now
okay when i say no assets you don't have
a car here in america
you don't have a home in trinidad
you live with your parents
i can see through all this y'all really
hurt y'all need y'all need to really sit
down and talk about it it's symbol and
y'all ain't talking about it she really
trying to open up and express to you but
y'all just sitting there well maybe
jabrie's mom is a therapist i guess this
is his way of mediating
i can cut the tension in the room you
know what i mean like she y'all hurt
we're about to get to him in a minute
but first two more things when it comes
to shaida and bilal
after his wife and his ex discuss the
issues they have with each other and
have had or have with him
sean asks bilal how he's feeling
um you know it doesn't
doesn't feel good
you know like when you hear like
lecturing you know those are probably
things that i've probably done you know
are neat freak for sure you know but
we live in an oppressive word
environment
and words make people sahitha is looking
like uh here comes another lecture like
words could you know
give you life
or it could cause destruction
i'm a loving
you know husband a dedicated father you
know do i have my faults yeah but i'm
trying to
look internally you know and to uh prove
self
i got to go to the two shed and and get
to work
the tool shed and get to work lots to do
in the tool shed
you know when i spoke to shada and bilal
earlier this season after he started
getting tons of backlash
i asked him what do you think all of
this is teaching you
here's what he had to say yeah i've
gotten
phone calls i've gotten like emails i've
gotten
uh
the like the the stuff that
people say is like wow and for me like
i've been a person who has really i
guess
pretty much all my life to try to stay
a certain way and being you know
disrespectful towards people to get some
of the back there's like i've never
experienced that before in my life
sometimes
you know things get to you and
you'll be like hey like you remember
pray for this you know and the reality
is that we didn't we we decided not to
we decided to move forward because we
felt that god was answering the prayers
for us to align us this way like we
wouldn't have even done this and we felt
anything different so i just had to keep
that perspective like you know that this
is it's just a test you know and
you know i always say for every level
there's another devil so at the end of
the day you know you just got to keep
moving forward it's so wild how life god
the universe whatever you want to call
it
test us on things we could never expect
just when you think you have it all
together or you pass certain lessons it
will pop back up like hey
did you grow
let's see the good news though is that
everything is always working for our
good if we keep our mind open to that
perspective i hope a loud doesn't wallow
in the negativity but he actually uses
it to develop
also before we move on to jabrie
gibrisi
me and these nicknames
shawn asked shahida how she felt about
chada's reaction to bilal's family's
home and she says she was hurt for bilal
i lived in that house for two years
that was his family's home i was
grateful to have a home to come to so
for her to show that that display
i was taken back i was hurt
i respect her opinion because at the end
of the day an opinion is like a news
everybody has one
so shots fired requesting backup i don't
know what's going to happen between
those two
in the words of shahidah
good luck
jabrie first of all thank you for
dressing up for us
moving on cassie says they left all the
drama for the tell-all she says the
rating of this season is going from a
six to a ten very quick
girl jabrie was the one to take it there
and i have a feeling that that was his
intention
your family and friends had many
concerns about your marriage to niona
how is everybody getting along now they
see i'm happy they see that i'm really
just pushing forward and i'm doing well
and it's a lot of jealousy that's what i
feel like so it's been it's been rough
jabrie what do you think your family and
friends are jealous of great question
sean
we look good together
we shine
now
i was expecting a more complex answer
than that
what is this high school
we shine so when you shine people try to
dim your light wait a minute your mama
and your daddy who love you are mad
because you and your wife look good
together
i don't know jabrie that seems to be
what you prioritize
if there's a problem with a
mother-in-law then it's kind of on the
sun a lot of time because the sun maybe
is not not giving the attention or maybe
miona sort of came off as being a little
bit defensive like you know in the
beginning when she met your family so
maybe they felt like oh like what so you
think my mom is jealous
[Applause]
you're the most jealous person on this
whole cast so how are you gonna say that
my mom well if i'm jealous can i
recognize jealousy right obviously he
wants to be because you're jealous of
everything
wait didn't he say his family was
jealous jabri what do you think your
family and friends are jealous of we
look good together
we shine
the only family we've seen have an issue
with his relationship is his mom and his
dad
things turn up even more when the
spotlight transitions to ari and benny's
storyline
and the topic of ari getting jealous
over binyam training with the girl mma
fighter comes up because what happens
when he does win this fight and gets
he's getting a million dollars a fight
you know how many girls are going to be
chasing you and you are gonna be losing
your mind y'all ain't gonna work out and
i would say the same about you guys but
no it ain't gonna work out for y'all
you don't think arya benny's
relationship is gonna work out y'all
fake y'all ain't gonna work out
perfect ari said oh
jabrie why do you think they're not
going to work out i know they're not
going to work out nothing i don't think
she's too jealous
she's too jealous that's you're holding
him back she's holding you back bro
you a star it's funny because jabrie is
telling binium what people including his
best friend have told him about miona
he's one of the most talented people
i've ever met when he's motivated and he
has a goal you can't stop jabri that's
why i'm so confused where how he doesn't
see this because that fire just
deteriorated that fire is just
gone miona she holds him back
isn't that something she's holding you
back she's not a star she's dimming your
light i'm just being real with you
shots fired
shots fired
why isn't binium saying anything
once again people are coming at his
woman and he is tight-lipped all right
last but not least because some stuff is
going to go down next week let's take a
look at jabrie's sparkle argument with
patrick's brother john
and for context for those of you who may
not know
john has a very unique personality it's
just who he is but he loves his brother
that was like three weeks ago as john
was chatting with thais about their
issues jabri budson
you drunk right now
jeffrey drunk yeah how many beers you
drank this morning bro okay man i had
six last night damn well you've had the
12-pack this morning oh man your
sparkles are blinding me though bro
you know what i'm saying i'm trying to i
don't know if i can focus something
shining off your head boy you can see
that yeah put that
i've never been a good joner some people
are good with comebacks clearly
do you think your brother is whipped
yeah
yeah
100
yeah without a doubt i love you though
love you but you definitely wept you
went you happy you don't have a happy
family
you won't
okay spackles
okay experience no [ __ ] never you
were joking i was just having a
conversation with him but then you
opened your mouth no you were joking and
then i have to respond i apologize you
need to stop third-wheeling bro
third-wheeling yeah you all in a
business like this your brother how's
your family doing on your father it's
not your brother
brother he's still living there and then
you're still living at home you're
talking about come on sparkles you're
talking about girl right now come on and
the sparkle beef continues next week as
those two threatened to get physical
are you crying nah i'm crying it sounds
like you're crying i don't want you i
don't want it to escalate to that point
you know what i mean oh if you're going
to bring it bro you got to take it yes
you know what i'm saying you giving
you're going to be the one taking a lot
okay sparkles
i'm going to knock him out if you bring
him up no you're not
no you're not that's not how that story
ends
who do you think will win between jabrie
and john
i'm just saying don't answer that but on
a serious note jabrie has been spewing
negativity all day
i'm not surprised that he's finally met
his match
we'll see what happens
all right 90 day fans fam make sure you
stick with et because we are covering it
all i will see you next time
[Music]